americans are being bled dry at the gas  pump and the high energy prices are not  only emptying our wallets but also  driving up the cost of virtually  everything else that we purchase but  never mind all that the white house is  claiming victory because gas prices  declined a little bit last month that we  are currently experiencing the fastest  decline in gas prices in over a decade  if a gambler loses his house at the  casino and then the next week wins back  a couple hundred bucks at the slot  machines  that does not mean that he is a winner  he is the opposite of a winner he is way  way down americans do not care how fast  or slow the gas prices change  they care  about what the gas prices are